like i see a lot of these guys and every
time you know almost every course that i
looked at was like these guys aren't
making any money
eventually it came down to i just
realized that some of these guys and a
lot of them i'd say a majority of them
are just straight out lying
and so i came i wanted to kind of change
this whole industry i was kind of
i'm he's sitting here frustrated why are
these guys
out here and how are the people giving
them money
and they're not even showing their p l
like how does that even
factor in like i don't understand it so
i decided you know
i'll start showing my peanut and maybe
change the industry to where everybody
has to show their p
l to be credible
ladies and gentlemen welcome to
coffeezella another episode of sunday
special where i talk about whatever i
want today we're talking to carl
dom the owner the operator the channel
manager the creator the writer
for real p and l because real traders
show
their p l carl thanks for coming on
thank you for uh being a part of this
and informing us
about these fake traders i appreciate
you having me and this is a big
honor for me to be on your show for sure
when did you start getting interested in
the gurus because now when you go to
real pnl a lot of it is like
you know reviewing core sellers uh
especially specifically option traders
courses and uh you know calling them out
if they're
if they're scamming people or they don't
really have the the stuff to back it up
when did you get into that yeah so it's
been a few years so maybe i can
go back about 15 years or kind of that's
fine just start thinking about who the
biggest scam is because i'm gonna ask
you a lot of questions and people want
to know
who the biggest option scammer is raging
bull we're gonna get into all of it guys
um you know 15 years ago i have my
business degree
uh i own real estate you know when i was
19 i always
tried to figure out the most economical
way to make money
and that was always my goal from the
start so stocks or options or whatever
weren't necessarily the thing
you know i was in real estate i owned a
laundromat i had my broker's license for
real estate in california
15 years ago i had some money saved and
all this time
up to that point i really wasn't trading
successfully
i was trading online but i was losing
money but i wasn't satisfied what was
going on so
i looked at other opportunities like
franchises or
you know just other businesses but they
all had that drawback of time
you know they took a lot of time so i
really liked the online thing
so i was really drawn to the online
trading thing but
but i hadn't been successful at that
point in fact in 2008
i had blown up my account for the sixth
time
that was the last time i blew up my
account by the way tell people what
blown up
blown up means you know i had a you know
sixty thousand dollars now i have
eight thousand dollars right it's game
over
right in fact in 2008 talking about game
over i had sixty thousand dollars on the
account
i got a phone call from the from uh i
think of snickers swim at the time
they told me i owed them 120 000. so not
only did i lose 60
i was down 120. so
i've been there um that one ended up
where i just
had to write a check for 12 000 so i
lost my 60 plus 12
but it did set me back a little bit yeah
yeah yeah so i have a lot of experience
when it comes to trading options right
what not to do
right um but i kept learning i kept
focusing
it really got serious in 2011 up until
that point i was just really hard-headed
i only
i just wanted to do what i wanted to do
i
didn't want to listen to anybody else i
didn't read any books i didn't
take any courses and do anything but in
2011 i started getting a little more
serious about that and i started looking
at other
potential people that i could learn from
and i started looking at courses i
started reading books
and in 2014 i found this
website called tastytrade and i think
anybody that trades options they
probably have heard of them
and the good thing about them is their
business model allows them to
to show you everything they're not
hiding anything
and so i learned a lot from them and
there's a lot to learn from them and
really a lot of the stuff out there is
just rehashed from tastytrade
but at that point i also made a friend
his name was john pope online
and he said hey you know i want to look
at some of these
guys online some of these courses and
you know a lot about auctions can you
help me out let's take a look at a few
of them
so at that point i started looking even
more deeper into these guys that were
trading options so i
i don't know how many courses i looked
at in 20 30
and you know that's a lot of courses
yeah i looked at a lot
and he found you know he was looking at
a few of them too
and in 2017 i came across a really good
course and i learned the next level
you know you know you have your tasty
trade levels and you've got that next
level stuff and
when i learned that next level stuff
that was the point where i kind of
figured it out you know i kind of turned
the corner
and you know started making real money
good money
you know at this point i understand how
to trade really well
and i'm looking at all these
gurus that i see online and i'm like
these guys aren't really real like
what's going on here
like i see a lot of these guys and every
time you know almost every course that i
looked at was like these guys aren't
making any money
so you know what's the i asked myself
what's the most efficient way to
evaluate these guys
because i'm just evaluating these guys
and i'm like
what's going on here you can't tell
what's real what's fake you make money
who's not it's
not national i can't tell who's reals
what's fake i can tell they're fake
so why are they in business because like
that's the question that i'm asking
myself
sure and how can i get to the bottom
line with these guys
you know for other people i mean i
obviously i'm okay
but like i'm just kind of like why are
these guys in business so then i kind of
narrowed it all the way down
to i need to see their p l
like if i can see their p l
then you can see whether they're real or
not profit loss statement profit and
loss statement like
a real profit and loss statement on
their account they say they make all
this money
well where is the proof of all that you
know
so i realized that was the best way to
figure out if if an instructor was
credible was
showing a p l so i started i went on to
youtube
i started asking in the comment sections
of these guys
saying hey can you show me your p l
you know i wasn't being in you know i
was being cool about it i wasn't being
like
you don't know what you're doing show me
your piano you come on you know
i'll prove it you know i wasn't like
that i was like hey can you show you
know for me
it's helpful if i could see your p l
that would kind of help me out to prove
that you're credible you know
and how many people on average which
show
i'd say it probably has like i don't
know 35
i would say one oh my god
maybe two i mean like none of them i
mean
their accountant said that they couldn't
show
it legal reasons they couldn't show it
uh
and that's all bogus i mean curious
various excuses
yeah if they're actually making money
they'll just show you their their profit
law statement
exactly i mean how
it eventually came down to i just
realized that some of these guys and a
lot of them i'd say a majority of them
are just straight outlined
they're just there's a slide i mean i
it and so i came i wanted to kind of
change this whole industry i was kind of
i'm
sitting here frustrated why are these
guys
out here and how are the people giving
them money
and they're not even showing their p l
like how does that even
factor in like i don't understand it so
i decided you know
i'll start showing my p now just to kind
of hey i'll be the guy
to show my p l and maybe change the
industry to where everybody has to show
their p l to be credible
so i started my p l for a while um
and nobody watched my channel
so i thought you know how about if i
take the course and i do a review
and i show the results of taking the
course
and then people might be interested in
my channel and then i can kind of get
the point across or kind of get
show everybody hey this is what's
important
you're taking the course and you're
actually what are you doing their
trading strategies how are you
evaluating
their course yes so i'm taking the
course
and they have like an alert service
right so they'll say
buy this option today you know
today we're gonna buy these these this
spread or this option
and then you know and they might give
out two three alerts a
week maybe five alerts a week just
depends on who it is
so i take a 25 000 fake money account
because there's no way i'm gonna put
real money
and i put their trades
in my account and at the end of the day
i'll do a little
video and say okay so today they said
that i wanted to put
you know x y z long whatever
and so at the end of the week i'll do a
little
preview and say okay well here's how i
did for the week yeah you know i'm
supposed to be making one percent a day
what's that five percent i should be up
about five percent this week and i'm
down seven
you know that kind of stuff i mean one
guy
went for five weeks i went five weeks
fall every one of his trades
and i was down 36 percent oh my god okay
that's not the end of it he put out a he
put out who is this who is this
guy i can't some names and names i i
don't want to get on
but sometimes i can say things sometimes
i'm
a little bit uh you know i want to hold
back a little
legally bound i got you go ahead yeah uh
so
the thing about this is he had an
advertisement that came out that said
during the same time frame that i took
his course
that he made 1.7 million dollars
i lost 36 percent he made 1.7 million
dollars
in the exact same trades same trade same
time frame
so i mean well unless he did different
trades so you're gonna tell me to do it
the guy's straight up the guy is
straight up lying scamming whatever you
want to call it
uh what else are you gonna do
and that's the sad thing is people chase
these guys because they go man if this
guy can make 1.36 million
i can make that hey it's easy
it's easy right yeah so it is very
interesting
but my question is do you think there's
any way to fake a p
l how would you fake a p l i mean could
you photoshop it my question is is
if somebody shows their profit loss
statement does that mean without a doubt
these people are real no
um a lot of times they'll show
their p l maybe they show it at the end
of the year maybe they show their p l
maybe they do
show it okay but what i do is also when
i show my p l i show my daily
uh balance of my account so you can see
what has happened every single day so i
do it at the end of the month
now people might show their p l at the
end of the month
but if you don't see what happened what
happened with their account over that
time period they could have been
they could have been down 60 or 80 and
got lucky and got this big turnaround
thing and just
you know got lucky that month i like to
use the analogy of let's say that you
have 128 monkeys flipping coins
right and every time they flip heads
they stay in
so you flip and they're 64 and flip
those 32 you flip they're 16. you flip
there's eight
flip again there's four monkeys left
does that make those four monkeys an
expert on flipping
heads are you gonna pay those monkeys to
flip heads
no they got lucky okay so sometimes you
know
statistically there's guys out there
that get lucky and they show their p
l but do they need to show their p l
over time
of what happened with the account over
time also
right right because if you're down in
history
you're down sixty percent you're if
you're down fifty percent let's say you
start with a hundred thousand dollars
and you're down fifty percent
what kind of returns do you need to get
back you don't need 50
returns to get back you need 100 returns
100
returns to get back to even sure so a 50
drawdown in your account is like a major
drawdown it's like a major
loss that you have to recover from now
these guys
sometimes they get lucky they have a
major loss and then they recover
and then they show their piano but a lot
of times i see these guys showing their
penis or they
what they do is they show trades
individual trades winning trades
i call it the shiny penny syndrome it's
like say you have a jar of pennies
and you just find the one that's shiny
you pull it out and you show that one
off
and then you go in there and find
another one well
there's two pennies that you pulled out
out of 20
or out of 10. what happened with those
other 10
trades you know all i see is the winning
trades i don't see any losing i don't
see any p
l i don't see anything significant but
these winning trades so i one guy on his
channel had
over the last maybe two months he had
maybe eight winning trades or ten
winning trades
like he had one on the first one on the
seventh one on the 15th
i said okay cool you know so i
uh went into the comment section and
said hey what happened on the first
the third the fourth fifth sixth seventh
eighth you know
oh he says he didn't trade those days
okay he only trades the days he wins
he only impressive yeah he only wins and
he only trades the days he wins
some other guy he
hypothetically he trades low float
stocks
and he gets in
but he's on a time delay so he might be
five
ten seconds behind before all his
followers
realized oh i need to go long this stock
and so you got 20 000 people or 5 000
people or whatever the number is
getting along that stock well guess
what's going to happen
it's gonna go up he's already in it and
then he gets out
and then 10 15 20 seconds later
everybody else learns it's time to get
out
so this is the kind of thing that is
you're saying this hypothetical person
is like
it looks like front running trades which
is actually a way to be very profitable
as a trader if you have an
army of loyal followers and you front
run trades
yeah it's very very easy to be
profitable yes and i believe this
hypothetical person i'm talking about
uh does that has that particular skill
so yeah interesting i i just wanted to
know what you thought yeah
uh what do you think i mean obviously we
can talk about
raging bull as well they just had these
you know these accusations come out um
that's massive for the community i think
a lot of people of the traders are
looking at that like
maybe i should cover my ass a little bit
maybe i've been
it's been a little loose these
regulators they don't do anything for
like a while and so people get lacks
and then they come with the hammer and
nobody wants to be the guy to get
squashed
yeah so that so i think one of the
things you were talking about
earlier or i know that you're going to
bring up is who do i think is the
the worst one right yeah but i kind of
think
there there's either people that are
kind of good
and then there's people that are bad so
there's people that are
when i say they're bad i really mean
their psychopaths
they they lie in order to get away with
things and they feel better if they get
away with it than they do by showing
empathy
and i think that there's people that are
on that side
and they're all pretty much
equal except how
how far are they willing to go how much
do they think they can get away with
right so i think the guys at raging bull
thought they could get away with a lot
more
than some of these others some of these
other up and comers
that are on their way to trying to get
away with more
so that's kind of the way i look at it
as far as
you know who's the worst well they're
all really bad and it's just
who's willing to push it who's willing
to push it the furthest and i think
those guys over at raging bull
they were pushing at the hardest and
they got they were pushing really hard
did you hear at one point uh jordan
belfort had a little thing going for
them some kind of free newsletter or
something like that yeah i heard he had
joined the club
over there yeah i i just thought the
irony was too rich you have this guy
who literally went to jail early on in
his career
doing some shady stuff with stocks and
all that and then
he gets out says i've changed whatever
oh by the way hey come learn come learn
about stocks
they like how does nobody think that's
hilarious like it's
that's crazy that's insanity to me it
seemed like jordan belfort
almost turned his reputation around like
he seemed like you know
maybe he kind of flipped the script a
little he's trying to help people and
all that and then
as soon as he got in bed with bridging
bull i was like why did he do that he
yeah it seemed like he was kind of
turning his reputation around and then
he just put it all back put it all back
it's
weird i mean he's gonna say like well i
didn't sell
but we all know that you're tr what the
effect
of going into bed with people like that
is as more people get in
and we all know where it goes from there
um
ricky gutierrez what do you think of him
let's just go let's go
let's go through it well ricky i haven't
taken his course
so okay it's hard for me to
to say really what ricky is or doesn't
do
definitely looks like he makes a lot of
money but
i think he's very similar to
he said what i remember ricky's one of
his videos he said he could make one
percent a day or that was his goal
because it was so easy to do
yeah he's like a conservative two
percent or something like that
a day he's like conservatively my goal
is two percent a day it's like
two percent and you had the other
gentleman on uh
the smart financial guy i'm trying to
remember his name right now plain bagel
or patrick boyle
patrick boyle and he did the
calculations on the two percent a day
and that was like
i don't know three years from now you
own everything
in the world i mean come on of course i
mean i had a two percent of date here's
here's a two percent a day guys so they
have an account worth a hundred thousand
dollars
and they make a trade for 500 they spend
500
on the stock and they sell it for 520
so they made two percent on their 500
but they when they when you see their
advertisement you're thinking they're
making two percent on a hundred thousand
dollars every single day
when the truth is they're making two
percent on whatever trade they did that
day which is 20 bucks
you know that's how they kind of do that
one that's one i found but of course
that i took
yeah well you also said there's there's
this technique which i thought was
fascinating i
never thought about this where a guru
will take
both sides of a trade they'll take oh
they think it's gonna
they'll take they'll go long on one side
go short on another account and then
they'll show you the gain from the side
that's right
in in actual fact they make no money and
maybe lose a bit a bit on the spread
but then actually they're showing you
that they made all this money this day
because you can place like a big bet
knowing that you can't really lose
hardly anything
yeah exactly so they'll set up two
accounts they'll put you know they're
making a lot of money from their courses
so they might put a hundred thousand
dollars in one account hundred thousand
dollars in the other cap
go long on one go short on the other and
they show their shiny penny
but see where is the p l on the total
portfolio
i want to see the whole portfolio
because you can't do that
when you're showing your daily uh p l
and
you know maybe you show it at the end of
the month you can't play both sides of
the
of the trade so that's the reason why
they don't want to show their whole
piano
i had another guy who uh was one of
those four monkeys
that flipped heads just super lucky yeah
got lucky
so he does show us p l so he's he's okay
so he does show us p
l but this is how he did it he's got
this
he's constantly showing how he's a great
trader
and he won the world's trading
championship which i tried to get into
but i don't know how you get in like
there's no way to get in who is this guy
who doesn't even exist
his name is chuck hughes he's on cnbc
and all this kind of stuff and he's
like yeah i show my piano so i'm like
what
shows his p l oh he showed his tax
returns
from 1987. oh my god okay
and this is 2017 and he's out here
saying
oh yeah i make all kinds of money and
i'm really good and i show my p l i show
my tax returns
well if he made money in 2014 or 2010 or
2008
do you think he'd show those to tax
returns also or just tomorrow
1987. of course he would of course he'd
shot if these guys were making money
wouldn't they show their p l i mean yes
i got there's this one lady that
says she turned two thousand dollars
into two million dollars in two years
and she did how coincidence what a
coincidence that they're such nice
numbers they're marketer numbers
that's why it was easy for me to
remember right yeah two to two
so she's on her webinar with her cohort
or her co-host and the co-host says
oh yes and i've seen her true results
i've seen her statements
well i took her course and i said hey
can i see those statements of course
they're
not available now if you turn two
million
two thousand and two million in two
years you'd want to show everybody
would your statements be available yes
of course
of course i think i think that is true
also like when you look at tim sykes
he's always touting like i turned my
fifty thousand dollars into one million
dollars
twelve thousand into five million there
you go
there you go and it was back in like
1999 or something it was like a long
time ago he still cites that as like oh
that's who i am
he's like have you done anything since
what are you doing he's like no i'm an
educator
i'm really a million-dollar uh trading
uh
uh students
that's what he has now yeah well it's
it's just very interesting that like
he's always like yeah i don't i can't
trade for more than that
how coincidental that he just makes just
enough money to be able to teach you how
to get rich
but not more than that to make it worth
his time to continue doing
well when you trade low float stocks
that's then you know what happens you
can't get up into the millions right
maybe not yeah sorry he's making so much
money on on penny stocks
speaking of i've heard of this guy that
uh
is claiming to be real i don't know if
you're going to take a look at him in
the future
you heard of steven ducks heard of this
guy
i have heard of steven ducks now he is a
he i believe he's a student of timothy
sykes
no i don't think that's correct i think
steve timothy claimed him as a student
i think stephen docks is like he's like
like doesn't want to be affiliated with
uh you know i i that's a video i would
definitely like to see
i if you're if you want to get into
because he says this is like one of
these guys who says look i release my
um state i think he releases all his
account statements or something
uh even like emmett from
tradingschools.org
we talked about him he thinks stephen is
real
um so i'm interested i'd love for
someone to like kind of do a forensic on
his
and i would love i would love to do that
but this guy's crazy
he wants like five grand to just walk in
the room
and i'm like five grand you know i gotta
i gotta save up for that i mean come on
man
so you should send them a message i bet
i bet we could find a way to get you a
key some kind of access
or something like that yeah i mean maybe
after this video he'll maybe after this
video he'll give you a thing because
he seems to say oh i'm real i'm a real
trader
and that's the problem right it's like
surely some people
are real traders but and as you said
they're like they're guys out there with
real strategies
the problem is separating the 99.99999
nine percent of people from the 0.001
and then also aside from that problem
which is already hard enough
the question is are these strategies
reproducible
and why and how
that is really the key when you talk
about stephen ducks
from what i've heard from my inside
information that i
have you know i have friends in the
industry that's the problem with his
system is it's
not duplicatable by its students now
maybe he makes money but it's not a
duplicatable thing
i don't know if he makes money i just
heard that it's not a duplicatable thing
that's one of the
issues with with ducks well it is the
problem right
with like any kind of uh skill
anyways is that you know you could have
michael jordan teach you basketball
you're not going to shoot a ball like
michael jordan like it's like the
classic thing
and so the thing that i tell people is
learn your basics for free get your feet
wet
go go uh really get your hands dirty
with something before you decide you're
gonna spend two thousand dollars
a thousand dollars five hundred dollars
on anything because the truth is
nobody can hold your hand through that
first effort bit anyway anything you're
gonna excel at you need to just put a
certain amount of time in
my biggest pro like problem is all these
industries are preying on beginners
they say we're going to teach you the
basics of forex like that's going to do
anything for you
right and that's exactly what these like
you said earlier that's what these guys
hide behind because they know more about
options than you do as the new guy so
you're at this
you're in this learning phase you could
technically learn from a lot of these
guys even though they're
not making money but you could learn
from them
but the thing is they're just rehashing
things
that are already out there well known to
everybody
i have a list of questions that i ask
every course that i take and one of them
is
do you have a proprietary trading system
because if you don't
why am i spending any money on it
because i can go to tastytrade
i'm not saying tastytrade the way they
trade is the best way i
i wouldn't trade like that but if you
want to learn
how to trade options for free go there
i mean that's the solution right there
and then once you start
getting above once you understand what
they're doing and you're ready to kind
of
understand that some of the stuff
they're doing isn't working but you're
at that level
then these other guys that are selling
courses and things they can't do for you
with anything because they don't know
any more
than what you can learn on tastytrade
i hate to promote tastytrade so much but
if you want to learn for free
they have a great business model that
allows you to learn for free
yeah and there and there are people like
that in every industry i know i know
forex they have babypips.com i believe
is the name of the website
where it's the same thing it's free
bunch of educational things
investopedia has great articles there's
a bunch of ways to dip your toes into
all of this stuff
now let's talk about actual strategies
proprietary strategies
and testing because all these guys are
gonna say
look i'm making millions i'm doing this
i'm doing that
but there's very easy ways you could
test a lot of these strategies
using historical data and kind of hold
them up to the test
can you talk about that well first of
all if
if they're training a system that is not
something that you can back test
then it's probably a subjective system
in other words they kind of change it as
they go
and if you're going to change the system
as you go yeah if you change the system
as you go that's not really a reliable
system that's repeatable so you can
eliminate some people from that point of
view like
if you follow this guy's trades because
he feels like you should go long here
and then short here and then next week
he wants to go short on the same stock
and he's kind of going back and forth
and he's really just kind of being
subjective about it
that's not something that you can repeat
it's not a repeatable thing and you
can't backtest that kind of thing
um technically it is proprietary but it
doesn't mean the guy makes money
right just because he picks a stock to
go along or every other week
it's it's a proprietary thing because
it's like whatever's in the guy's head
right
sure but it's not that's where you
definitely need to see p
l but when you get to the back testing
part you need something that's black and
white with black and white rules
because if you have that then you can
take it back i like to go through the
last 10 years typically
so whenever i see a system i have one i
i took one course
where the company or the
guru or whatever you want to call the
instructor had uh a portfolio a standing
portfolio
at that moment so as i came into the
course
this is what they had done over the last
30 or 40 days right
it's there right these are the trades
that hadn't been closed out yet right
so what i did is i picked up that
portfolio
right and i duplicated it
back in february of 2020
and i ran that same portfolio through as
if there was a crash
and it was down 68
so yeah these guys are killing it
they're making money right now
but what about when the market crashes
what's going to happen so you have to
take all that into account
so that's why you want to pick up you
want to take these systems that these
guys are saying if you can take the
rules
and back test them in other words you
take them through real data
as if you were trading that system over
the last 10 years you know yeah in 2016
2008 through like different because you
had you had the may
markets the may 2010 flash crash you had
the august
24th 2015 crash you had the february 5th
crash
you had the march 2020 crash most
options trading systems
don't survive those crashes if they're
selling premium if you're buying premium
that's different those are low
probability trades you really don't want
to go there with that that's
that's not what you want to do you want
to sell premium that's where the edge is
and options but people that sell premium
they don't take into account
these markets that come up these crashes
that come up
and when you get when you get when the
market crashes you get a margin call and
when you get a margin call that means
you've got to exit your position at the
worst possible moment
and you're going to take a 50 haircut 80
hair whatever it is you're going to take
a big haircut
you know and these guys are trading as
if the market's never going to crash
ever again like that march 2020 oh
that'll never happen again we'll just
keep
we'll just that's the issue is that like
um i feel like our education around
finance
especially online is so bad that people
think that if this guy's making money
today
well that's fine i'm making 20 today
i'm fine actually the funny thing about
it is that as you make money
losing percentages becomes worse and
worse and worse like taking a
50 cut from like once you've built up
your account after all these gains all
these gains is way worse than taking a
50
cut early on anyway i find it very
interesting that we
live in this world where people don't
envision
the crashes that come up again and again
and again nobody thinks are going to
happen
yeah and and i also have a thing that i
always show which is the cost of
drawdowns right if you have a
if you have a drawdown i don't have the
thing in front of me but if you draw
down 10
you need to make 11 to get back the even
no big deal
if you draw down you know 50 you got to
make 100
to get back to you you draw down 70 you
got to make like 200
to get back to even yeah let's let's
explain that to people real quick
so like let's say even account of a
thousand dollars
you draw down 50 you're at 500
now how do you get back to a thousand
dollars you don't have to make 50
percent of your money because if you
make back 50
of your money you're only at 750. so you
have to make a hundred percent of your
money back
to get where you started at a thousand
dollars which is very kind of
counterintuitive when you first hear it
it is and that's the key to being
successful trading
is to have low drawdowns when you
they're going to be drawdowns
everybody's going to have drawdowns
but you've got to keep those low and
that you that way you can survive and
it's easy
you know warren buffett's uh rules you
know it's two roles of management number
one rule is
don't lose money and this number two
rule is refer
to rule number one
yeah well well yeah and a lot of people
have beaten warren buffett over two
years
three years but that's why he wins in
the long game
but in front he's he's so revered is
because
he remembers rule number one and he
remembers role number two
and that's like that is really the key
to a lot of trading
is to take the l like sorry
investing i guess in his case but
traders have to think about this too
traders have to think about these losses
because people you can do well well well
but like
you know from blowing up your account
six times um
is brutal don't remind me sorry
i mean so yeah you know uh
i was gonna something else about that
yeah so the guys that beat warren
buffett
they're one of those four monkeys that
flipped heads you know
what's going to happen next year are you
going to beat them again next year i
mean 20
that's a big that's a big number you
know that's the other thing these high
expectations
these guys saying you're going to double
your money in 90 days
uh you are going to make it crazy it's
crazy it's become totally unrealistic
the market is so crazy right now what
people expect is
lunacy they go why would i invest in the
s p look at the low returns just a
baby returns it's like those are good
most people don't beat those so you have
this
so that's one of the things i've noticed
about youtube is uh over the last three
or four years or whatever the time frame
is that i've been kind of looking at is
that
guys used to say i just made five
thousand dollars in one day
and then the next guy says you know what
i made eight thousand dollars
and the next guy says you know what i
made 22 000.
now you've got guys saying they made 350
000
in one day like it's just outrageous
the the claims that they're making well
they would say like i just need the
views
they're click-baiting they say i'm
click-baiting man just get over it i'm
click-baiting whatever it's like no but
you're also saying you made this much
money
it's not i mean how much do you think it
is like
i really think it's partly because we
live in this culture
of short attention spans we want it now
now now
and the barrier to entry everyone's a
robin hood trader now
everyone it has access to advanced
uh financial tools
but without the financial education to
use those
tools appropriately i mean i see guys
doing
they're telling people to go get you
know 10x
margin go get go leverage yourself a
hundred
x it's like what that's that never
i mean normally you wouldn't you
wouldn't be an investor with access to
those that kind of leverage
well this is kind of a new thing if you
trade stocks
you kind of have that 50 margin or you
know maybe you're gonna
lay down ten thousand dollars on a trade
and you're kind of risking ten thousand
dollars
at that point with options
you can sell premium and you can say
let's say that you sell premium and they
hold five thousand dollars in your
account right they're holding a certain
amount of money for your
for that trade it's as if you bought
something right they hold a certain
amount
but the difference with options is that
margin can expand
in other words it was five thousand but
now it's twenty five thousand
worth of money pay up twenty five
thousand so that's the problem with
options and people need to kind of
realize that part you know and that
usually happens when there's a crash
market too
and there's just like yeah and the
margin and you get margin called meaning
that you you have to pay up because they
know they're afraid you're going to not
be able to pay
so then they basically force you to blow
up your own account right
yeah because they you you actually owe
them money
because the guy on the other side of
your trade is owed more money than what
you have in your account right and so
they're like wait a minute
we're as us as a broker we're going to
be on the on the hook
we can't have this we're going to shut
this guy down right now
and uh hopefully he doesn't have to
write us a check
that's right right and and maybe you
could have like held on but if the
margin call
is high enough you just have to do it
that's you get screwed right then and
there
maybe you could have held on a lot of
times you could have held on and came
back but
the broker is not going to front you for
that right you're not going to take that
chance with you
right so they're going to tell you you
need to you need to wire funds into your
account you've got 24 hours you've got
48 hours to put 10 000
into your account for example or we're
closing out your position
we're going to charge you you owe us
five thousand dollars
you know you got margin called you lost
everything in your account plus you owe
us money
do you think it's smart that everybody
just has access to all these financial
instruments i mean do you think there
should be like some kind of a
literacy test before you go and you give
people
these kind of more sophisticated tools
well
one of the most sophisticated tools is
called portfolio margin and that's when
you can really really leverage up really
high
and for td ameritrade you have to pass a
test
to get that i agree with that yeah but
there's other
areas i don't think with the interactive
brokers i don't think you have to pass
the test so
you're in a situation where your margin
can just expand on you and you like
don't know
you know you don't understand it it's
possible but i would rather keep it
open to people to do whatever they want
than to put restrictions
i i don't like yeah yeah that's fair you
know
if you want to blow up your account six
times go ahead but you know
at least you learned something
hopefully hopefully you learned
something um yeah no i i just wonder
yeah i saw some crypto youtubers they
were
recommending a hundred x leverage in
bitcoin and it's like
i can't even that's the disaster waiting
to happen because
you've got to be you have to pick you
have to pick the correct direction right
you have to be directionally correct
right you have to
i believe the bitcoin is going higher
right and if it goes lower
you're down or you believe it's going
lower and if it goes higher you're done
like picking a direction for me is
another thing that i i have
for me personally i'm i have a different
view than a lot of people
i don't believe that people can really
pick a direction in a market short term
and manage money around that and make
money now a lot of people out there say
you're saying no the speculative traders
yeah or the guys that use technical
analysis with a chart and all that kind
of stuff
i don't believe they can really do that
kind of stuff now i haven't
i've seen a couple people do it but i
really think they're just coin flippers
you know what are you here you're much
more like a burton malcolm guy like like
efficient marketing that's actually my
favorite book
uh random walk down wall street yeah
random walk down
wall street mine too yeah yeah awesome
book
and basically the price the price of the
stock you don't know if it's going to go
up or down because
all the infrared everything's kind of
priced in already so what makes you
think you know more
than the next guy well so so that's the
interesting thing
is that uh you know some people are such
die-hard fans of the chart
and they swear by it they're they've
even been
legendary traders who've used the chart
um but i was just reading just today
about this
what's the book um this guy follows a
bunch of traders around
he interviews them and then uh
wizards market wizards yeah market
wizards
and some of those guys they use they
they use the chart i mean
so i i don't i but i i'm agree i agree
with you i think most of it's just hey
there might be
nonsense there might be a few of them
out there
i know and i have you know i've been
part of that mastermind group and i know
that certain people believe that they
can do that kind of stuff and they
believe other people are doing it
they might be out there it's definitely
not duplicatable
it's definitely not going to be some
course that you're going to take and
you're going to be able to
you know trade like that guy you know
right because a lot of it a lot of it is
kind of like uh
subjective like they're like i'm jumping
in here because of the trend line and
the moving average and the fibonacci
sequence
but if you ask them that same trade the
next day they might feel differently
about it
because you can endlessly rationalize oh
that's not you know a consolidation
that's
that's breaking through the support no
of course
oh i think it's going to do this i think
it's going to do that because i've asked
people like why not just make a trading
bot
to do the trades
you've got to have the black and white
rules and if you don't you're being
subjective and if you're being
subjective it's not
duplicatable and i don't think not only
is it not duplicatable for other people
i don't even think the guy who invented
it could duplicate it if he doesn't have
black and white rules
set up for it yeah it's tough
it's that's that's really tough for me i
don't i don't really understand
i wish more studies were commissioned on
retail trader performance
one thing that i really get frustrated
by is academic
um academics and finance have not done a
great job
of capturing day trading
retail trader forex trader performance
they've like there's a
there's two great studies from japan and
brazil and i always cite those
but people go oh that's that's japan and
brazil what does that have to do with
the us
and every time well of course
yeah of course i believe that but like i
really wish some of these
some of these you know academics and
finance
would just do bigger and bigger studies
to just
finally convince everybody like i don't
know what it's gonna i don't know maybe
maybe no one will ever be convinced
maybe everyone will think they're always
the exception because they're just
trying to get rich quick
but i wish there were um
hard more hard data on this i think the
more hard data the clearer the picture
is going to become
but who's going to finance that that
study you know because
these brokerage uh the brokers aren't
gonna it's a huge conflict of interest
it is oh it's a massive conflict of
interest because they want you to
they're like a casino who wants you to
believe oh yeah you can win
oh yeah play more at the tables we want
you to play because if you believe
you're the guy who can you know day
trade
your brokerage fees through the roof
yeah whereas if you're if you're a guy
betting in the
the s p or some broad-based index
hey it's the worst thing to ever happen
to brokerages
because where are their fees where the
commissions where how can they pay for
all their money because they can't
justify a huge fee anymore yeah
and so they're not going to go ahead and
finance that study that's for sure so
it's not coming out of there
you know one of the things i i have a
list of questions that i always ask and
interesting that i always ask one of the
things i always ask is what is your edge
right
you know i get into a course i get
behind the paywall you know i get an
interview or
i write an email what's your edge
and these guys don't even know they
don't have an answer
like how are you selling a course and
you don't know what your edge is
like how does that make sense it doesn't
make sense to me
no it makes no sense i mean that is that
is the you got to measure your alpha i
mean i'm always telling people this
um and so when i ask them like oh how
much do you make as a trader a year
they go oh well i don't really measure i
don't really measure that
i just take some of my profits and i
kind of i just don't measure it
and i'm like wait what yeah you can't
come they go you can't compare me
to invest an investor well why not why
can't i compare you to an investing
performance
well i'm like at the end of the day
you're gonna have
a return right after fees after it's all
been said and done
there has to be some performance metric
otherwise
we're it's all pixie dust if we can't
measure anything
exactly and that's why i asked for p l i
got yeah
back to your thing you know you got to
see the daily
uh moves you know you've got to see
these things
or they're just not credible i mean it's
just the bottom line i mean
i i really like to get the bottom lines
all the time and that's kind of my
personality and
that's what i do i just ask them so who
else have you
investigated so um
let me look that up that's a question
that i
who are you investigating right are
there some people you're investigating
right now
and some what are some of your stories
about because i like the story of you
going in the guy says he made a million
he actually
lost 30 percent what else do you have
for me
i mean i'm sure there's all sorts of
horror stories from these classes
i don't know if you see my video on
jason bond or not with his weekly
windfalls
go ahead i watch part of it yeah but he
says you know
i he says he makes money trading both
ways so when the market goes up i make
money when it goes down i make money
and jeff asked him well what happens if
the market crashes and then jason says
well funny you would ask that
but i'm protected on both sides
and then i sh and then i shift over to
the video of him
showing his results and he talks about
how he got killed how he started with
200
well he was up 250 000 with his trading
system
but now he he got shot down and he's not
doing well and he's losing money
well did he ever back test this i mean
he just
i thought he made decides on made money
on both sides of the trade
yeah so how could he lose money during
the crash
and why would you why would you sell
something if you don't back test it to
prove that it works or doesn't work and
then
i think weekly before they went under by
the
but before they got investigated i think
wikileaks still available
even after he showed his i found that
video of him
they lost he was up 250 just think if
you would have started that course
when he was up 250 000 and he went down
like 250.
like you would have just got annihilated
so that's um
oh my gosh man that's insane to think
about
and let's see let's see some of these
other stories like
oh another course i took they claimed
that i could make a thousand dollars a
month
and just spending 30 minutes or less per
day
so i'm like okay cool you know this is
going to be awesome right i guess
thousand dollars a month with what kind
of account size
account size sizing
what yeah yeah yeah that's something
that you talk about here yeah i never
hear anything
about sizing that doesn't even come in
just a thousand dollars a month got it
so i get behind the paywall i take the
whole course
not one time did i hear the word
30 minutes a day that one time did i
hear the word
a thousand dollars a month or the phrase
oh the old bait and switch bait and
switch i mean they switched into
nothing like at least you should if
you're if that's what you're
selling you should at least address that
issue in the course you would think
right it wasn't even stated they didn't
even talk about it
it's so lazy dude it's such a it's such
a lazy industry carl
uh that's what i'm finding is that the
actual people who do this
tend to be
really unsavvy investors who like got
killed in the market and then go hey you
know where the real money is they
actually realize something profound
which is
you can't you can't do teach i mean it
is sort of an
old expression but um and they realize
the real money is
if you can't trade the real money is in
selling a course
why not it's all about the marketing on
the front end you get to the back end
and there's nothing there
yeah and so like before you take the
course you should see the p
l you should see the p l you should see
the back test
results you know these are the kind of
things that
i would hope that i could help change
the industry and
i would hope that other people would
look for the p
l you know before they even get into the
course
you know i if i could do that that would
be that would be awesome i mean that's
what i've been trying to do that's what
i've been aiming for
for a couple for what about a year and a
half now however long i've had my
youtube channel
so what about um there is a problem
where i mean obviously as you said it's
great if they show like daily
more regular p l's but what happens when
somebody's front running a group
and they're making money because it's
actually
kind of trivial to make money when you
can sort of control
low float stocks uh s
so what in that case because you'd see
you could actually create a p
l it's real you're really making a ton
of money
but you're burning all your subscribers
while you do it well so what you do is
you you i don't know if you want to make
this public or not but
what you do is you put a
non-disparagement agreement in your
sign up and therefore as a student you
cannot talk about
what happened behind the paywall
i've heard about this actually just
recently i heard about this
and it's just horrible because it's like
i know
i took a course i he's making all this
money but i've lost my ass but i can't
tell anybody about it
because i signed this agreement you know
wait so you signed up
but that's kind of is that even legal
like imagine
i don't know if it's enforceable i think
it's not enforceable but i haven't been
to court you know i don't know i'm not
an attorney
i would say that's probably not because
imagine you went and you bought a
product and
buying the product made it so you
couldn't talk about how bad the product
is
well that seems like some sort of fraud
because then
no one could ever find out i mean it's
like a consumer rights issue
like how could you put a
non-disparagement agreement into
a buy clause so that as soon as they
bought it
now they can't ever review the course or
review the thing
well i've asked one person in particular
uh
that i heard that does this but i don't
really want to name names
and uh he wouldn't respond to my
comments so i'm assuming they're in
there
the non-disparaging agreement's in there
because if it wasn't i'm sure he would
have said oh no we don't have that
well no i i've seen it in the the
purchase clause of a lot of courses
um now you can find ways around that i
mean you can
not pay for the course not that i would
ever recommend anyone do that
not that i would ever recommend anyone
go pirate of course but
uh that is one way around it um but that
no that sucks
yeah that really sucks yeah and so
you know one of the times one time i got
behind the paywall and
and um and this one guy recommended a
stock but he said
take a look at it you know i'm looking
at this it's on the radar
right well that stock went from ten
dollars to like thirty dollars the next
day
so the next day he comes out and says
hey
uh i just made you know 30 thousand
dollars
i'm glad that everybody else was able to
capitalize on this trade that i
recommended
he didn't recommend the trade but then
he holds us a webinar with the people
and he's kind of like saying
hey uh i i
this alert was very clear i said buy
the stock and i look at the alert that
he puts up like on the screen
and the alert says buy the stock but the
real alert says hey
this is on the radar so he made up an
alert as he went along
that made it look like he made all that
money then he got pissed off
acted like well i don't know why you
people are complaining if i tell you to
do something you should do it and that
this is proves that you should
need to listen to me and i was just like
oh my god
i don't know what to do with this guy
except for making video
that's crazy i'm blown away by the
stories you have and what i love is that
you actually get involved
in the back paywall or behind the
paywall i mean that's what i'm starting
to try to do i have a show called weekly
wednesdays or webinar wednesdays where i
actually do that as well
because previously it's just i just
evaluated marketing because that's the
easiest way to kind of like
kind of sniff test somebody but
eventually you do kind of want to get
behind and see what is this person
actually doing
and i will say i almost expected to be
maybe wrong about a few people if
anything i'm more sure than ever
with my first thesis which is that
98 maybe 99 of this industry is just
full of garbage
and they are taking profits from
desperate people who want to make money
fast in most cases it's very sad
uh but i appreciate you appreciate you
coming on the show i think um
i think we covered everything yeah i
just want to say i i
i i have a certain personality
where i'm not going to just use hearsay
or maybe antidotes i mean me personally
i have to go back
i have to go behind that paywall and i
got to see what's really going on before
i'm going to say anything because i'm
not going to just make anything up i
want to know the facts
i try to be as objective as i possibly
can
and so for that i need to go back i need
to go behind that paywall and be ejected
i don't want to slam somebody that
doesn't deserve to get slammed or
anything
in fact i don't want to slam anybody i
just want to tell the truth you know i
just want the truth to be out there
and you make your own decision based on
what my findings were
and that's kind of how i do it me
personally i just want to be as
objective as possible
well i love it i love it i think your
channel is gonna do really well because
i think
we're in a world that just needs more um
sort of objectivity around this this
marketplace as you said there's so many
incentives to lie so many incentives
to kind of tell half truths um and so no
i i appreciate
appreciate your channel guys the channel
is p l the real p or sorry
real p and l look it up you can also
look up carl dom
carl with a k dom with two m's um but
thank you so much for coming on the show
really appreciate you coming on and
sharing everything with us i appreciate
being able to get on your show it's
gonna help my
channel grow and this is like a huge
honor for me to be on your show
i really appreciate it yeah love it love
what you do i hope to get the word out
and i really appreciate
everything that you're doing show your p
l all right
i'll see you guys tomorrow
[Music]